my
good afternoon and welcome to at yale
live i'm eric gershon
in four days the nation turns its eyes
to washington for the second
inauguration of president barack obama
there will be song prayer speeches
poetry all part of a pageant
choreographed for inspiration and effect
to help us appreciate the art and stage
craft of this rare american spectacle
we're joined by a pair of guides
well-versed in art and performance poet
elizabeth alexander is chair of yale's
african-american studies department and
a professor of english
she wrote and delivered the inaugural
poem
for president obama's first inauguration
and is one of a tiny group of inaugural
poets in the history of the united
states
joseph roach sterling professor of
theater at yale is an expert in
stagecraft and performance and an astute
analyst of theatrical display thanks to
you both for being with us today
pleasure thank you so
elizabeth let me start with you what was
foremost on your mind
four years ago this week in the days
before you read your poem praise song
for the day at the president's first
inauguration
well at that point the poem was written
i finished it about two weeks before the
inaugural by the skin of my teeth
and so
that was the largest word that i had
going into the whole thing was was the
thing itself the thing that i had to
produce
and mostly there was excitement and a
whole lot of questions about the pageant
but more so excitement about the fact
that we were actually about to
inaugurate
barack obama i mean if any of us takes
ourselves back to
going through that campaign the election
and the aftermath
that's where i was thinking that it was
amazing that we were about to
welcome this president and his family
and what about now four years later how
how is your
is it again just excitement there's
presumably a little less pressure this
time
yes and that's very nice um it's lovely
to be madame spectator um it's wonderful
that there is another poet whose work i
love and i'm excited about what he's
going to do so
it to be on the sidelines of that um but
to also know that
obama has
hopefully kept this tradition going that
will continue after him of having a poet
at the inaugural good good and i'm
hoping to get some of your thoughts a
little later in the program about him
um and this question is is for both of
you really aside from its massive
audience
which i assume to be a good thing
in what ways
is the inaugural ceremony a desirable
forum for art
well
the occasion
uh is not only a massive audience but
it's a selected audience
it's citizens who want to participate
by being there in person
and
the
great space the public space of the
nation opens up and receives
a multitude and then others join
and see it in a mediated way
but they choose to be a part of it
understanding that they'll be a part of
history
and they'll bring their children
to enter into that space so that their
children will remember having been a
part of history and they'll bring their
children to the
to the screen to see it and classes will
uh
stop their work in schools and this the
children will watch the inauguration to
be a part of that history we were
reminiscing a moment ago about the
kennedy inaugural in
1961 and there was a poet
at that inaugural as well
and uh i remember it as a seventh grader
that's right robert frost i remember it
as a seventh grader we stopped class
and
we watched the inaugural and it's a
vivid memory that piece of history is a
part of the way i view
myself as a citizen
and i just wanted to to add to to those
those beautiful comments that um as far
as arts place uh
in in that
um
you know to say that art has a place in
civic discourse to say that art in in
different forms uh has something to say
to the citizenry about what it means to
be american because i mean i think that
you know to take it a step further that
is also
the question that's called what is this
american-ness what does it mean to be
american together
and i think there are some things that
art can say and do that political
language can't or won't and that's why
it's so wonderful to have it there are
there are there
are there particular things that
political discourse can't say or won't
say that that you have in mind um well
you know i think that there are ranges
right that there are registers that
there are tones that there are nuances
that we are not likely to hear in
political speech
so
it's just another
mode of address
but i think that if that means as
listeners as spectators we
can be worked on in various registers i
think that that enhances the power of
the feeling
and meaning of the day
joe if you were advising the inaugural
committee on how to script the ceremony
what might you suggest are there
important elements missing
or there elements that you you view as
sort of overdone or underdone we've just
been talking about how it is a great
forum for art but not all art forms are
represented or can reasonably be
presented in a single in a single
ceremony
well um i wouldn't criticize
but
i would have
all of the artists perform live as
elizabeth did so memorably
because at that moment and this is
building on her comment but i want to
say she set the bar high for all
subsequent poets because the poet's task
i think is to speak not only to
the public
but for the public
not just to america but for america and
elizabeth did and i'm so proud of her
for what she did that day for
uh as a citizen and as an as an artist
for all of us
but uh
i would have it all live i wouldn't have
for instance of the greatest cellist of
our time
on a pre-recorded tape pretending to
play
at the inaugural i would have
yo-yo ma play live in real time even if
he made a mistake because it's all right
to make a mistake
robert frost had a very difficult time
reading
from his uh text because the sunlight
was so bright on that brilliant
uh january morning
and
he couldn't read off from the glare so
he struggled but
it was
still a
great
public poem by robert frost and
many of the words rang out nonetheless
and
his struggle was part of that
performance so i'd have it be as real
as
robert frost's performance was as real
as elizabeth was in real time speaking
with transparency and i must say
elizabeth didn't make any mistakes
well but unless there was a word that i
missed
you know i didn't make any mistakes but
that's so interesting because i've
always felt
protective of the great yo-yo ma having
heard the stories about you know
instruments and cold and hands and cold
and you know all of the things that they
can't do and i sat next to aretha
franklin
as she
silently meditated preparing to get up
with her throat thinking about what it
was so cold yeah and we were on the
stage for a very long time actually
before the whole ceremony began
at least an hour with no warmers of any
kind
so
you know those instruments the musicians
hands the singer's voice the cold but
when you say
let it be real let there be room for
error
um let it be the thing itself i i love
that
yes well good point about
the
physical limitations on
that kind of authenticity
but still uh i'd take other measures
maybe throat warmers and hand warmers
and uh sometimes uh even yo-yo ma makes
mistakes under ideal conditions in a
concert hall well that's right yeah and
he's still great he's still great so
it's is it it's the spontaneity of life
truly live performance right that gives
it an additional an additional edge and
also i i guess that's a comment but also
a question
um it is it despite the possibility of a
mistake that actually endows it with
with a little more energy exactly yeah
that's the the essence of it it's the
humanity of it
just as in a democracy itself you don't
always get it right the first time
or sometimes the nth time
but yes let it play out as it will
another dimension to that just uh
speaking from a certain kind of
aesthetic
i think for me in in
making it work
it's important to coordinate between the
elements
and if one set of performers is in one
plane and another set of performers is
in another plane one live one
pre-recorded
i think there's a kind of dissonance
there that we'd be better without
because the president will be speaking
spontaneously although i'm sure it will
be carefully rehearsed and i'm sure he
will have
a prompter but even so he's making those
words live in real time and i would have
everyone on the stage with him in the
same world
elizabeth i have to ask did you did you
um i couldn't tell whether you were
whether you had memorized the poem and
reciting it from memory or whether you
were occasionally referring to a text uh
i i memorized it um
in a number of ways first of all i lived
with it so intimately and so intensely
that you memorize text that way it just
kind of comes into your body and you
know it that way but also i memorized it
and tested myself because
knowing the robert frost story you know
i had i had them you know tucked here i
had i had extra copies i didn't i wanted
to be at the ready because of course who
knows what they're going to do when they
get up and look out at a million people
um
i thought that i would account for that
in advance
so i was i was
referring to a text but i had read the
text
now having having grown up in the world
excuse me
having grown up in washington um you've
been to the mall presumably thousands of
times and probably did some pretty
extraordinary public events there when
you when you got up there looking out at
the sea of people before the mall
was that was that like a brand new
experience that is or i should say of
course it was but in what way was it uh
well it was um it was on a number of of
wonderful um kind of continuums for me
um the larger historical continuum in
which the moment was new um was you know
i looked out and walt whitman's work had
been so important to me preparing the
poem and thinking about his idea of
trying to kind of cast around the
country and listen for american-ness
you know how do you how do you sort of
do that how do you tune your ear to that
and so you know i pictured the hospitals
of civil war dead on on the mall and
walt whitman tending those those people
i pictured all of the protests on the
mall over the years i pictured
suffragists i pictured the march on
washington which i had gone to in the
baby carriage with my parents i you know
i saw that great tradition of protest on
the mall that is a part of what america
is i saw
myself and the president and others on
the stage standing on the steps of the
capitol and thinking about the slave
labor that built that place where we
stood so there was all of this
remarkable
history and yet a moment that was
brilliantly
new
um
and then though in the moment i wasn't
thinking about the personal certainly in
the time leading up i mean i was six
blocks from my childhood home
um i was somewhere they there didn't
used to be all the security all over the
the town so
you know when i was a teenager that was
where you'd go to smooch that was where
you'd go and walk around whenever you
wanted however you wanted
we used to go and and hear the naval
band and see fireworks on the 4th of
july just stroll down and see that
inaugurals for us growing up were
a time where especially if we didn't
like the president where we would uh be
annoyed at the influx of tourists
disturbing our neighborhood and uh
making everything closed down and
complicated so
the intimacy of
i was in my neighborhood
and
that was beautiful although that was not
on my mind when i was up on that stage
then it was sort of the larger moment
and and even as a poet i was not
important the poem
poetry was important the word was
important the larger occasion was
important
well speaking of uh occasion um i want
to ask about the the kind of poem that
you wrote and that you read it's often
referred to as at least in the at least
in the news media as an occasional poem
um and
if you would just tell us a little bit
about exactly what it is that defines an
occasional poem and what if anything
renders it
in actual form not just substances is
different from
uh a sonnet or any other kind of poem
people might be familiar with um yes and
and joe will have something to say about
this as well so an occasional poem is
literally a poem written for an occasion
it could be a sonnet
it could be a haiku it could be
in any form but occasionally marks the
why of it the how it it comes to be born
and the expectation that it will in some
way whether directly or obliquely
address its occasion
in some ways i chose to be a little bit
oblique with the occasion i wasn't going
to say hurray barack obama i wasn't
going to say inaugural there were some
words that were not going to appear
there but it was occasioned by
this moment this shift this incredible
hopeful
promontory on which the country i think
felt itself
standing um and i thought about because
i work with different forms sometimes
making
changes in them but but starting with
form i thought about a prey song which
is actually a west african form
and would also traditionally be an oral
form
because what was unusual about this poem
as opposed to any poem any poet ever
writes is that most people will never
read it
you see
and
most people you know you write poems to
be read but most most won't so i thought
it was kind of interesting to have
something that that came out of an oral
tradition
that was meant to be declaimed that is
to say the praise song um and not again
to make it about the singular barack
obama but to make it about
the country that had brought us to this
point
so um
if if a person had never heard
uh praise song for the day your poem and
had only encountered it in print
are there elements of it that mark it as
or they're recognizable to a person
who's somewhat familiar with poetry as
an occasional poem um
well the in its official title it's
praise song for the day a poem uh on the
inauguration of barack obama and that's
a that's a part of the title that's
always meant to be it isn't always
printed with it but it's meant to be
gotcha but in its form i mean it has
other
principles of formal organization it's
got a regular metric it's got regular
stanza form and so forth but none of
that is in any way tied to what an
occasional poem because an occasional
poem can take a lot of different though
it is tied to what an oral poem is a
poem meant to be spoken yes yes yes
did you want to comment further on
yeah there are so many rich ideas here
about what it is to speak what it is to
speak poetry
and
the
process of making
a communication
to a general
public but one that is yet in a way uh
intimate to the occasion because it's so
special
and
one thing that elizabeth
demonstrated
in is what in my world we call the
illusion of the first time
that is a speech that is carefully
written carefully rehearsed polished but
then so well polished and rehearsed that
it comes off as if it's being spoken
now in real time as if the words are
forming for the first time in the
imagination in the heart of the poet and
being spoken as we hear them
and that's a great gift and great
political orators have it and great
poets who are poets of the spoken word
uh who can read and i put the word
read here in quotation because most
poets who are great readers have their
poems well to heart yeah they're
performed almost more that's right but
of course the magic of it is making
people less conscious of the performance
than they are of the words
um
i think many people think of poetry um
as a slow deliberative contemplative
spontaneous art form uh something that
is born of
of of a germ of a feeling um
and not something like a newspaper story
which you know is almost uh defined by
the fact that it's going to be written
on a deadline and so the the concept of
deadline poetry as it were almost seems
a little bit like a contradiction to me
and i and i wonder uh if you tell us a
little bit more about composing under
those circumstances yes because i can
assure you no one is ever waiting on the
other side for
other poems there's never
any sense of time uh unless you're
writing for
you know a dear friend's wedding or
something like that but um you know we
write as it comes although also you know
if you're serious about it you
stick to it so that you are present when
it chooses to come so really the
discipline and practice are much more
important than the inspiration it's
about being where you're supposed to be
uh when good words and ideas come and
for me and i think for many poets too
the germ is not so much in an idea but
it's a germ of language a sprout of
language a word a phrase around which
things are built within which ideas are
are contained
and so
this was very different there was a very
very short time period um in which to
write this thing and a kind of a you
know
drop-dead deadline i mean you know no
wiggling uh uh no nothing um
and not to mention i mean you know
putting my whole family and everyone who
loved me through you know we couldn't
drag it out any longer than uh than it
then it went so it was an intense couple
of weeks um
with many many many many many many many
drafts how how much advanced notice did
you get december the 18th
okay so about a month
well but it was done before had to be
done before well of course or i had to
be done before right of course you know
you know i would be in a hospital yeah i
asked elizabeth a question yeah please
go ahead um
i'm just wondering and this is uh in a
way out of line because it's sort of
like asking a tennis pro where she puts
her thumb on the racket
and
i don't want to mess up your game
but when you created it i want to ask
about performance too but when you
created it
the the imagery of those simple things
the
the the celebration of those simple
things that made
the uh elusive uh language of the poem
to the world
uh at truce that the hand could touch
at an arm's distance we could touch them
are those the things that came first
i'm trying to remember what came first i
knew that that was what i had to do
and i knew that for example when i'm
writing poems that don't have a place at
the end of the day um
there's a way in which
you know people ask did i try to write a
poem that was simple and
no but on the other hand did i
avoid something so esoteric that it
wouldn't
have meaning to many many people i mean
you you can't speak to everyone but
you know you can imagine some exercises
that simply wouldn't have been
appropriate for the occasion um so in
thinking about
first images
um
yeah it was it was early on it was
fixing things
fixing
fixing things mending the uniform you
know the darning the uniform mending the
tire
fixing things um also the the teacher
the teacher says pick up your pencils
begin came early on uh needless to say
and and my favorite story about that you
talk about all of um
the the ways that that that we are
citizens by watching collectively
someone wrote me a beautiful letter she
was a second grade teacher
and she had it on in her classroom and
her students picked up their pencils and
started writing oh my goodness when they
heard those lines in the poem
and many people said to me
um
you sounded like a teacher and they
meant it in a nice way yes
and my students several of them said you
were you you had teacher voice that's
right and i thought well that's a good
thing that's right i think that's it i
think it is too in in my world the
languages that's transparency
meant in a slightly different way than
it said in political uh context
meant
that you
you see the imaginative
uh being that's creating the work that
you're watching you're hearing those
words that that she is speaking yes she
elizabeth is speaking yes
if i may i'm going to read a short
excerpt from the poem and i'd love to
hear your thoughts on it afterward
we cross dirt roads and highways that
mark the will of someone and then others
who said i need to see what's on the
other side
i know there's something better down the
road
we need to find a place where we are
safe we walk into that which we cannot
yet see
say it plain that many have died for
this day
that just
sent shivers down my spine when i when i
first heard it and read it
there's it rings in a universal way
and to me
it also
suggests
explicitly references things that we
think of as american
work opportunity sacrifice
and i'd just love to hear you talk a
little bit about that particular part of
the poem
um well thinking about it's it's so
interesting to hear someone else read
those lines and it's also i'm feeling
that time has passed you know um
but um i'm thinking about the turn in
the poem which is right at the last line
that you read say it plain that many
have died for this day i mean that's
that's when you sort of know what you're
in uh and you know
you know kind of the deeper um
portent of of the moment you know let's
just sort of put it out there
um
and so
can you
just ask again what you what you wanted
me to say to those lines i i guess
you know everybody responds to a poem
and to art in general in a very
subjective way
and i guess
um i picked those out because they
stirred something especially especially
in me and
but you know the creator may have
intended something different or may have
a different personal response to that
part of the of the poem and i was
just wanted to ask you if uh if
if there was something specific you were
trying to suggest or
um with that yeah this is where i would
get even a little artistey
well because and say i'm so happy you
saw that and there you go i mean you
know i i didn't
the process of writing a poem is um
so
subrosa
but yet in that strata is all of this
structure and purpose
but the poet can't always articulate it
in the midst you know it's mysterious
but it does have a shape and an order
and a purpose so
um i can sometimes step out of my work
and and just be a a literary critic you
know or a teacher and say okay here we
see this this and this but my my
response when you read that is to say
i'm glad you saw that i'm glad it made
you feel something
and some part of me knew what i was
doing but it's not an articulate part of
me
um
i meant to ask earlier did did you get
much in the way of instruction or
guidelines were there any whatsoever
no and that's what um
i think was kind of wonderfully um
first time about the whole thing i mean
something else i remember about
everything leading up to the inaugural
is that it was kind of you know everyone
was going by this pulled by the scruff
of their necks like oh my god we we
actually won this election it actually
happened okay well we gotta
we gotta get the guy in we got to get
the guy up there we got to have an
inaugural we've gotta we've got to do
this um so i think that probably things
now are much more carefully
managed or managed with the benefit of
of experience
at the time being left to my own devices
what was so powerful about that was to
me it was the president and his
administration saying
if we picked you we trust you to do what
it is that you do we trust artists to do
what they do
so
uh i had to give the poem uh you know
48 hours before for the sign language
people
but it was long done by then um
so
that seemed to me to be a wonderful
faith in
in in art
you know each other well um did you
consult with joe or any other
theater folks before you went and
actually performed the poem um well i
didn't consult with joe but you don't
know the story do you know the actress
tamara tooney
she's a friend of mine and she's a very
fabulous diva
and at some point i thought oh this is a
performance i should i should consult um
and she's very grand and she also is the
person who said oh dear you must go to
an atelier and have a dress made i'll
arrange it
and so you know there was all of this
grandness which of course i i loved and
loved but she said to me
you know you might want to read this out
loud with someone else in the room
before you get up there and do it
and i thought you know no that'll scare
me more yeah you know or or
no
you'll you'll you'll make me accuracy
but i'll be bad accuracy and i you know
like no i didn't
i need to be myself
i need i know how to give poetry
readings and i just have to do it the
way i know how to do it but she said
darling come over
and read it out
and i read it out
and in that way that when you
read something you feel and hear the
words you've made
and i burst into extended
sobs
and thought good thing i got that out
you know i mean i really thought you
know it was it was a catharsis and also
it was like when you listen to yourself
for the first time yes and listen and or
listen to
the thing outside of yourself the poem
that you read at the inauguration was
the occasional poem that rehearsal with
sunni was your your occasion yes no
that's right that's right that's right
yeah how do you get to carnegie hall
practice practice practice practice
practice practice
and then she she said i'm only going to
tell you one thing
because then i thought what if that
happens when i get up there and she says
she told me two things the first thing
she says if it happens and this goes
back to your point about realness it
will be apt and beautiful
so
don't worry about that and then she said
and the other thing is she said remember
the people in the back of the hall
and so
that was great because
i don't know you would have language for
this at what
distance a poet would sort of
cast eyes and pitch
but she said
go back further that's right you know go
all the way back that's when it was to
the horizon yes
yes
so that was that was a wonderful thing
the conventional phrase is uh the second
balcony the second balcony yeah but okay
on your occasion or the inaugural
occasion it was it was the horizon yes
yes yes
um elizabeth i gather that you and joe
for all i know you as well have um
connections to uh this year's inaugural
poet richard blanco
um and i wonder if you've either of you
have had a chance to speak with him or
uh what advice you have or might give
him uh as he prepares to yeah do you
know him i don't know him personally
um yeah he's um i have known him a
little bit for a while um we uh his
mentor the poet campbell mcgrath is one
of my dearest friends uh on oldest
friends from high school actually
and so i've known his work and blurbed
his work and so forth he's a wonderful
wonderful poet we've emailed back and
forth and
i've congratulated him and just told him
that
you know
i'm with him
because i received a phone call from
maya angelou
who i'd never met
and
of course that was very different she's
an elder she's you know
but she
gave me a wonderful benediction i i
wouldn't presume to do that in quite the
same way to mr blanco but
it was
powerful and beautiful to be
called into
the history of the small community of of
people who have done this thing
um any any thoughts based on your
familiarity with with his his poetry and
his his mentor and what we might expect
from him on monday
um you know i think uh he's he's a
lovely lyric poet
his he is very interested in
american-ness
and in making ourselves as americans
um and i think that that is an old and a
new question
it's it's one that that we continue to
grapple with that and that our great
artists continue to grapple with
um so i don't quite know what to expect
but uh
that's that's where the work is coming
from
i i suppose it's really just trivia but
i was i was very interested to read that
he is trained as an engineer
and um you know perhaps i'm just
playing off stereotypes but i don't
think of of poets as having you know
this sort of rigorous uh scientific
training that um that
that he obviously has so it'd be
interesting to see if that well yeah
emerges somehow but but it's all you
know we all have our structures our ways
of finding structure and so you know
auden famously said that writing a poem
is like solving for x
and
i can't do math but i have solved for x
and it is like solving for x
you're you're trying to make your way
creatively to resolution i think it was
maxim gorky who said that poets are
engineers of the soul
ah
even better that's great that's great
so the president of the united states
obviously has many occasions uh during
the term to address a mass audience um
and
global audiences
do you either of you view the
inauguration as a special opportunity
for
the president any president
to communicate
something in particular or in a way
that the office doesn't doesn't often
lend itself to
what do you think
i would say that yes and of course there
are great precedents that the president
president obama must feel now such as
lincoln's second inaugural the words of
which are the kind of words that get
carved in stone
but
in this inauguration
even more than than most
the opportunity to speak to everyone as
everyone's president
seems to be a great challenge and an
opportunity after a very divisive and
bitterly fought
election
and with a
political difficulties
in the offing
it's an occasion to step back
and to think of the larger project
in which
everyone
who cares about the country is engaged
and and i think also you know
what are his modes of address i mean he
has the state of the union which will be
shortly after he has press
conferences and then he has
this president has
had some extraordinary speeches made um
at occasions of collective warning you
know the words he gave
in newtown and in arizona and so forth
and so i'm thinking about those
different kinds of of utterances and
what is different
from the inaugural and um
i feel like i could be wrong that that
we don't expect inaugural speeches to be
issuey
no like you know i don't think we expect
that he's going to
say gun control no even though that's
very much
something that he's dealing with right
now or he may but it would be elusively
evolved exactly because the inaugural
occasion
is as close to your art as it is to a
political speech such as the state of
the union or the acceptance at uh a
nominating convention the other public
occasions when there's a fairly well
worked out tradition of how you address
the moment
in in a way i i
i when i think of this speech
and of the um
demands on the on the speaker
and
the demands on this particular president
the moment that flashed into my mind
when you ask the question
uh was the moment in which uh the
president addressed his campaign workers
in chicago after the election
an astonishing moment because it was
both
as is his want under complete control
his effect was unchanging the vocal
quality only wavered once or twice and
yet he was crying tears that dropped
from his chin during that speech
and
i'm not expecting him to weep at the
inaugural but there's something about
that moment of reaching for the
subjunctive
the condition contrary to fact in which
hope is expressed
politicians often have to speak in the
indicative and the interrogative
this is a moment
when he is authorized to speak in the
subjunctive
i wish i were i wish we were yes
fill in the blanks yes
the the president obama is justly famous
for his oratory and so this would seem
the ideal occasion to draw on all of
those resources that he that he has and
that many don't
yes
um so let's uh move on briefly uh what
are your current projects what are you
guys working on now
oh joe what are you working on
a lot of different things there's
something you're working
paying the bills for our departments
right that's right elizabeth is chair
and i'm dus of theater studies
we're advising these wonderful yale
students and no but i'm i'm working on a
project that
came out of my
research in uh world performance where i
had companies visiting uh the campus and
my production team uh emily coates uh
and uh
and uh kate greer and others uh brought
uh artists from all over to to the
campus and indeed mobilize artists who
were on campus including elizabeth who
launched us by playing the um window of
opportunity meister in susan maury
park's premiere of her play cycle
was great preparing me for the inaugural
that's right we uh we rehearsed it here
first yeah
elizabeth had wings wonderful uh fairy
wings
coming out the back for the window of
opportunity meister
that was so much was it was a grand
grand site
um i am working on um a library of
america big volume complete history of
african-american poetry
beginning to the present so you're doing
a lot of reading so i'm doing a lot of
reading yeah i'm doing a lot of of
reading and a lot of archival work
actually because um there are um
some greatest hits that and some poets
who you just know you'll include but
really to do it properly what you have
to do is is first
read again for the millionth time
sometimes
and i said it chronologically everything
by a poet and also to do some archival
digging to find poems that appeared in
in
little magazines and so forth that might
never have been collected in in in in
published books um but that sometimes
you find tremendous jewels there so uh
you probably have a number of difficult
choices that you're going to have to
make obviously i mean that that's kind
of the hard work right of compiling an
anthology i imagine is deciding what you
have to leave out even though you'd love
to include it yes
and you know that's why for a while i
thought i was going to try to avoid the
contemporary because then it's your
friends
and uh and that is not easy but uh
you know to the true history
you know we are faithful so whatever
that may be that's what i've got a
you know kind of listen for um and it's
it's very exciting it's exciting also to
realize that this
field uh these poems these poets who
i've been thinking about for such a long
time that they can
appear
completely fresh
when you when you do a project in this
particular way um
uh are either of you attending the
inauguration this year you had a pretty
good seat the last time yes uh and i'll
be going with my with my sons uh we're
heading down tomorrow and we're all
excited about it fabulous fabulous i'll
be watching
excellent um as will i
uh well i want to thank you both very
much for for joining us today it's a
real special opportunity to chat with
you and hear your thoughts
and i want to thank all of you for
joining us for at yale live and hope
that you'll join us again next month
thanks very much
you